[Music]
decarbonisation it's a key factor in the
fight against climate change the goal is
simple to reduce carbon dioxide
emissions around the world as soon as
possible our planet cannot be saved
unless we leave fossil fuels in the
ground where they belong
decarbonisation requires both sweeping
change and incremental steps working
industry by industry process by process
in every major country in the world
sound expensive it will be but the
science community agrees to avoid global
catastrophe we have no choice but to
mobilize and take on this monumental
challenge renewable energy like wind
turbines and solar panels as well as
electric cars are the more popular
topics in the conversation but there are
other key sectors that are less
discussed and changes there are equally
important for decarbonizing the planet
here's three cement steel and
agriculture these three sectors combined
make up almost 40% of all carbon
emissions in the world what will it take
to revolutionize these three industries
without bankrupting cement is the most
widely used man-made material in
existence when combined with water and
aggregates it can be poured into
whatever shape is needed for
construction cement has been used for
millennia to build structures like the
Pantheon and Roman aqueducts to highways
and parking garages lots of parking
garages globally the production of
cement accounts for about seven percent
of yearly co2 emissions and that's
largely because of how cement is created
the main ingredients of cement is a
substance called clinker in order to
produce this limestone is heated to high
temperatures and usually this heat is
generated by fossil fuels releasing co2
meanwhile the chemical reactions inside
the kiln release even more co2 in the
process companies are working to reduce
the amount of clinker used others are
testing substitutes including fly ash
which is the residue left in chimneys of
coal burning furnaces or slag from iron
production but the drawbacks are serious
these new techniques come with a price
tag sometimes triple the cost of the
traditional process
since cement is holding many of the
worlds structures together alternative
recipes make contractors and regulators
uneasy
steel is just as important as cement and
as cities grow global demand is expected
to rise by 50% between 2019 and 2050 but
it's process involves purifying iron ore
in blast furnaces with a refined form of
coal called coke and just like cement
this production produces a lot of co2 in
Europe blast furnace owners are testing
hydrogen as an alternative way to take
the carbon out of iron ore but again so
far it's way too expensive to go
mainstream about double the cost of
using coke there's one thing you can do
with steel that you can't do with cement
and that is recycle instead of producing
more steel in the first place we can use
what we already have increasing the use
of steel recycling is now commonly seen
as critical to reducing carbon emissions
now agriculture requires a multi-pronged
effort as it is responsible for nearly
25 percent of global co2 emissions the
practice of controlled burns after
harvests the use of inorganic
fertilizers that release methane and
nitrous oxide into the air the
destruction of rainforests for ranching
and even livestock flatulence all need
to be addressed to put a dent in
Agriculture's carbon output some hope
can be seen in the US as demands for
beef products have dropped significantly
additionally interest in alternatives
like beyond meat impossible burgers have
soared in recent years and for those who
can't quit beef scientists are
developing climate proof cows with
digestive systems that produce less
methane but implementing these solutions
globally remains an uphill battle even
as more people in Europe in the US take
up vegetarian alternatives increased
meat demand in China and other
developing nations means that globally
animal product consumption is expected
to rise 60 percent by 2050 you are the
last best hope of
we are in the beginning of a mass
extinction and all you can talk about is
money and fairytales of eternal economic
growth how dare you
it'll take policymakers and companies
years of diligent work and collaboration
to move industry away from its most
polluting methods but each of these
industries is working on answers with
some executives confident they can be
both green and show a profit
[Music]
you